disintegrating as you're getting into it
painful prosthetics serious regrets
growing claws and sweating buckets
because of costumes just a day in the
life of the actors in the batman movies
i'm really unhappy we've got the inside
scoop on the pain the batman actors have
had to endure over the years from the
inconvenient to the horribly painful
number one
being a superhero costs it looks cool on
screen but in reality pattinson wasn't
feeling so confident in what felt and
looked more like a halloween costume at
first
wearing the 60 pound suit was described
as absolute torture
not to mention the fact that five people
had to help him actually get into it
christian bale did warn pattinson in
advance just how tricky the suit could
be which led to pattinson taking action
very quickly making sure the costume
design team could help him out
i'll say first things first i need i
need a patch i need a flap on the back
batman's gotta look out for each other
easy access number two
who is that actor none other than colin
farrell the performer looks
unrecognizable in the batman thanks to a
fat suit prosthetics and a lot of
detailed makeup the actor's face
couldn't move so easily with six
different prosthetics being applied
every single day and make up to touch it
all up the struggle didn't end there
though every single time before farrell
could get on set multiple crew members
were holding incredibly harsh bright
flashlights in his face just to make
sure not a single seam could be seen
number three
he did it for the part but he wasn't
happy about it paul dano brings the
riddler to life in the batman but
filming didn't come without major regret
from the actor regarding his costume on
set the actor came up with the idea that
his character could get completely
covered in plastic wrap as a way to not
leave any dna on a crime scene it seemed
like a solid enough idea and they went
for it but that's when the actor
realized just how big a mistake he'd
made my head was just throbbing with
heat i went home at night after the
first full day of that and i almost
couldn't sleep because i was scared of
what was happening to my head it was
like compressed from the sweat and the
heat and the lack of oxygen eventually
the team realized this wasn't feasible
for the actor at all so the designers
made some adjustments allowing the
actor's mask to be a bit more breathable
number four
this cat can scratch
stopping filming a couple months in
because of the pandemic turned out to
really benefit zoe kravitz when it came
to sinking her claws into the role
literally the actress collaborated with
the design team to bring her catwoman to
life and during her down time kravitz
was letting her nails grow out because
she wasn't allowed to get a manicure and
then the idea struck why not grow out
her own set of claws her pitch to the
team was crazy wonderful scary nails
that looked like claws she opted to drop
the nail polish to bring more cat-like
nails to the screen and while it wasn't
always comfortable who wouldn't take
advantage of this brilliant idea
inconvenient as it might have been for
kravitz and the team to maintain
number five
when robert pattinson went through his
batman auditions the production team
needed to know how he'd carry himself in
the suit so they had him use an older
batman suit and that's when he first got
a taste of just how brutal being batman
could be every single one still has the
actor's kind of sweat the actor tried
wearing the sue val kilmer war in his
screen test but the cowl didn't totally
fit him plus it was getting misshapen
because of how warm and sweaty the actor
was getting we're talking fully drenched
and then you're boiling i mean this is
before it even got the part this is the
screen test so he traded it in for one
of clooney's suits since it was the best
fit but that's not saying much because
it was still too tight even with the
measurements being a bit off the bat
suit was still pretty epic to experience
wearing for pattinson
number six
how tall is tall enough
pattinson measures up at six foot one
but for his chemistry read with zoe
kravitz it wasn't quite enough the team
needed to see pattinson grow a few
inches so the solution was to pair his
batman suit which didn't even fit that
well with a pair of high-heeled sneakers
anyone who's worn shoes with lifts
inside knows that they are not very easy
to walk in and when trying to convince a
bunch of producers that you should play
a superhero well it leaves an actor
feeling pretty uncomfortable with the
whole situation pattinson awkwardly
walked around not feeling very much like
the caped crusader he was trying to be
number 7 enter the visual effects
pajamas at least that's what ben affleck
called his not so traditional bat suit
he was rocking the full cg mocap suit
and while it might have been a bit more
comfortable it didn't make affleck feel
anything like the superhero he was
supposed to be it was the most
humiliating ridiculous thing in the
world for the actor but he knew that it
was a major benefit to the cg team the
suit just didn't match the vive he was
going for leaving him very uncomfortable
throughout filming it made for a very
gloomy batman
number eight
need some extra muscle there's padding
for that traditionally wonder woman has
had a pretty specific built physique and
gal gadot wasn't exactly what fans were
used to the actress worked hard to bulk
up and added quite a bit of muscle but
it didn't keep her from avoiding the
dreaded padded suit her wonder woman
outfit was stuffed with loads of heavy
and warm padding muscles chest hips
everything was amplified making for a
not so great feeling experience for the
actor
we ended up having i think over 14
different costumes
number nine
who knew his suit was to blame
christian bale and his batman suit
weren't friends for a few reasons the
poor ventilation for one leaving bale
incredibly overwhelmed and struggling to
breathe and leading to headaches on the
daily when it got cold the cowl would
get really tight leaving him struggling
to breathe so badly that he was seeing
stars having to deal with this nuisance
for so long it only made sense to try to
make the best of it so he brought these
annoyances into his character for his
broody and moody moments for the actor
it was just part of the gig
i'm getting the privilege of playing
this character i can't complain about
any discomfort of the suit his constant
discomfort and contempt for the suit
actually kind of benefited his
performance his bad mood became his
character and it worked considering his
first day on set was spent keeping the
suit on the whole time in an effort to
feel a little more comfortable in it we
can't say he didn't try to get along
with it
number 10
breathing not so easy in this gear the
bane mask tom hardy was wearing in the
dark knight rises looked incredible but
the experience of actually wearing it
let's just say hardy wouldn't be giving
it any five star reviews he wore the
mask throughout the shoot but it did
help with his character
i had something to moan about
legitimately hardy was a champ wearing
the claustrophobic mask that emanates a
certain discomfort for people who are
looking his co-star gary oldman even
called him very brave for donning that
painful mask the entire time
number 11.
yet somehow they worked heath ledger's
joker was a performance for the history
books but one of his signature
characteristics was courtesy of an
awkward and uncomfortable prosthetic the
prosthetic scars placed on his face were
falling off consistently and to avoid
having to go back to the makeup chair
multiple times a day for touch-ups he
just licked his lips ferociously to keep
everything in place and looking
joker-like he had to do it so often that
it only made sense to turn it into a
characteristic
the struggle was real and it worked as
he always had makeup on his fingers and
under his fingernails and everything as
he would have from from putting it on
just his hand number 12. she was fit as
a feline anne hathaway was cast as
catwoman and when she was the actress
went straight into the gym and worked
for a full 10 months the suit thoughts
of the suit changing my life so i would
fit into that suit it dominated my year
making sure she would fit into the tiny
costume was just half the battle though
i mean it's not a pair of sweatpants i
wouldn't describe it as that kind of
comfortable actually wearing the
restrictive outfit while filming was a
nightmare and drove hathaway to the
point that she was calling it a
psychological terrorist
you've given them everything
number thirteen
suit up or sew up michelle pfeiffer's
catwoman costume or as pfeiffer called
it the most uncomfortable thing i've
ever worn was so tight that she was
literally sewn into it pfeiffer would
get coated in powder to slip herself in
smoothly and then got vacuum sealed into
the suit for real it was probably really
unhealthy and it would literally just
start to squeeze my skin she struggled
as much as batman did when it came to
getting out of the suit to go to the
washroom always needing help to take a
bathroom break
i thought i can't walk
i can't breathe i can't hear eventually
the costume designer made some
adjustments so the actress could
actually get to the washroom more easily
but performing the action wasn't any
simpler
i can't act
fortunately production gave her a bit of
a break and she was only allowed to wear
the suit for a few hours at a time
number fourteen
it looks cool but it doesn't feel so
cool two of the og batmans michael
keaton and george clooney had to suffer
through two of the stiffest batman suits
in history filming was a brutal
experience because of how much action
they were actually playing out leaving
both performers extremely sore day after
day while both had stiff suits keaton's
was the worst one yet he still brought
an epic performance
number 15
superhero costumes were tough in the 90s
velkilmer suited up but it required a
bit of time getting out of it at the end
of a shoot that would be another 45
minutes needed to go to the bathroom
helpers were always required to make
that happen on top of it all the actor
could hardly hear with the heavy and
claustrophobic mask on
how he managed to so convincingly play a
superhero under these stressful
conditions really is a mystery
in gotham city looking this cool is
painful it's a cross every actor has to
bear but some got off easier than others
which batman costume did you like most